thank you
hey guys welcome to automation anywhere
full course in this full course we will
cover the core topics of automation
anywhere automation anywhere is well
known robotic process automation tool it
has grown in popularity over the years
and is now used by organizations all
over the world
automation anywhere enables it
departments to set up software robots
that collect and interpret data in
various applications assisting
businesses in successfully automating
their business operations
here is the list of topics covered in
the automation anywhere full course
we'll first begin with what is RPA
then we look at the 10 reasons to learn
RPA
followed by which we will see some of
the real-time RPA examples
proceeding further we will see
installation of automation anywhere and
automation anywhere tutorial
we will see how Excel operations are
performed in automation anywhere
proceeding further we will see some of
the important interview questions that
will help you crack automation anywhere
interview
proceeding further we will see RPA
developers salaries and finally how to
become an RPA developer I am sure you
are excited to get started with the
automation anywhere full course but
before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our YouTube channel and
click down the Bell icon so you never
miss an update from Simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started with automation
anywhere full course this is GM he is an
accountant in a multinational company he
handles several invoices and other
Financial records like monetary
transactions liabilities checks and
ledgers on a daily basis one of his
tasks is to copy all the relevant
information from these invoices such as
the name of the company invoice ID and
data processing into a spreadsheet and
mail the sheet along with other
Financial reports to a superiors by the
end of the day as any prompt employee he
transfers all the information to the
sheet attaches the reports and sends
them over to his boss via email every
day but over a period he starts finding
this task to be time consuming and
repetitive frustrated Jim looks for a
way to reduce the time and effort it
takes to complete the task and voila he
stumbles across robotic process
automation AKA RPA using robotic process
automation he builds a simple bot that
extracts information from several
invoices into an Excel sheet attaches
all the necessary Financial reports and
sends them over to his superiors via
email at a specific time every day so
what exactly is robotic process
automation robotic process automation
RPA is the use of software with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities to handle high
volume repetitive tasks that previously
required humans to perform some of these
tasks include addressing queries making
calculations maintenance of records and
Performing transactions there are
several misconceptions about RPA RPA is
not a humanoid robot it does not have a
physical form and no resemblance to
humans RPA cannot replace humans or
replicate human cognitive functions it
does not have a brain of its own and
cannot perform logical or critical
thinking as humans do the working of RPA
includes four crucial phases 1. the
planning phase typically involves
Gathering the processes to be automated
identifying the test objects and
finalizing the implementation approach
two the development phase includes the
creation of automation workflows as per
the agreed Plan Three deployment and
testing is a vital phase since it
uncovers any unexpected outages and
ensures a bug-free product 4. lastly
there's the support and maintenance
phase which ensures that the product is
continuously updated with smooth
deployment across the user base to meet
the objectives of RPA tools are used
these RPA tools are software
applications that can configure tasks
and automate them some of the popular
RPA tools in the market are uipath
automation anywhere blue prism
workfusion Pega and Redwood among others
when it comes to Quality RPA ensures
consistent error-free output leading to
reduced operational risks this in turn
improves customer satisfaction in the
area of delivery RPA can help decrease
the average handling time and this
enhances the customer experience and
ensures 24 7 business continuity with
respect to cost according to nascom
domestic businesses can reduce the cost
by up to 65 percent through RPA it
offers a higher Roi by driving positive
returns within quarters as opposed to
years other advantages of RPA include
reduced training costs minimal
utilization of it resources and easier
software migration today many domains
and industries like Banking and finance
it integration processes Human Resources
insurance agencies marketing and sales
and customer relationship management
readily deploy RPA RPA service adoption
has been showing tremendous growth since
2016 and will continue to increase
Beyond 2020. according to mckinsey's
research knowledge and work automation
could have an economic impact of five to
seven trillion dollars by the year 2025.
it will impact more than 230 million
knowledge workers which constitute nine
percent of the global Workforce any
company which is labor intensive where
people are performing high volume High
transaction functions stand to benefit
the most with RPA adoption boosting
their capabilities and saving money and
time
now that we've discussed what RPA is and
isn't here's a question for you which of
the following is not an RPA use case one
email query processing two data
extraction three image recognition
4. payroll processing
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below RPA offers
the ability to automate business
processes quickly and easily it paves
the way for digital transformation by
placing automation tools at the user's
disposal so what are you waiting for
get certified and become an RPA
developer to build a bright future in
the field of automation now let's jump
into the topic 10 reasons why you should
learn RP
but before jumping into it let me give
you a brief insight into what exactly
RPA is
now uh do you remember the time you used
the digital calculator it may be your
Calculus class
it made it so much easier for you to
arrive at an answer
calculators undoubtedly helped you solve
complex mathematical problems which
previously required a lot of time
and of course doing manual calculations
have inherently several errors
but does calculation account for
automation
well no a conventional calculator
requires manual input so this is partial
automation
automating the usage of a calculator
that requires zero human intervention is
what RPA does
so what exactly is RPA
robotic process automation is the use of
software with artificial intelligence
and machine learning capabilities to
handle high volume repeated tasks that
previously required humans
now some of these tasks include
addressing queries making calculations
maintaining records or even making
transactions
so why is RPA gaining popularity so
rapidly and why do companies and techies
have RPA perspectives
so here are the 10 reasons why one
should learn RPA
so number 10 fast implementation
now getting data entry Bots up and
running goes quickly
implementing a new RPA Software System
certainly happens much faster than
training a new person
you can have these data entry Bots up
and running in just days
in contrast if you wanted to hire a new
human employee you'd be taking a lot of
time in sorting out resumes conducting
interviews going through the entire
boring hiring process and then finally
when you find the right person you'd
have to spend time and energy on
training them
however in case of RPA all of this is
countered
and number nine we have no training time
so now this is an important one
if your process changes and the Bots
need to learn something new you can
either replace them with new Bots or
alter their programming
now that again goes much faster than
training employees for new tasks in
terms of costs training an employee for
a new task will pan out to be way more
expensive and time consuming
next up the Bots will never quit
now with RPA you don't have to worry
about employees quitting or dealing with
the turnover
Bots don't care how hard they're working
or how boring their job is or how
repeatedly they're doing the same tasks
again yes it would be ironic if the Bots
got tired
software Bots can work all the time 24
hours a day every single day of the year
at 100 capacity now RPA doesn't take
holidays it doesn't have sick needs and
of course they do not have unproductive
days at all
well isn't that a treat to have someone
who never retires or decides it's time
to move to a different job
next up minimal I.T resources
maintaining software Bots requires
minimal I.T resources in some cases it
doesn't it doesn't need to get involved
at all
your RPA systems will be managed by the
software provider the responsible for
maintenance and updates all of that it
completely takes the burden of it and
saves your company a whole lot of money
Roi is visible now every organization
wants to quantify their gains
many of these organizations do not know
how they should determine their Roi but
when it comes to adopting robotic
process automation Roi is visible it
defines a clearer path to demonstrate
its risk returns
complex problems can be solved now as
our data sources and analytical
capabilities have grown so has the time
required to build various reports
robotic process automation system is
ideal to for solution to solve these
types of problems
the system stores the information and it
can also remember and transform this
information very easily
that means this makes you auditable and
tax ready
software migration
now it's a fact that software migrations
are time consuming and costly
migrating to a new software could take
months and cost could turn out to be
tens or thousands of millions of dollars
what's even more frustrating is that at
all times certain features and
functionalities which may have
functioned in a particular way in a
previous version may not even be present
in the updated version
so RPA helps with data migration with
accuracy speed and continuous updating
of software
RBA has a free tier
many RPA vendors offer free tiers
some of these vendors are blue prism
automation anywhere uipath among others
these RPA software vendors are offering
High RPA software notably uipath with
their Community Edition and web fusion
with their RPA Express
this helps lower the total cost of
ownership
there's no rip and replace
now RPA doesn't jeopardize an employee's
job but helps with the growth of new
jobs
to do your work you need some additional
software yes and virtual machines to
deploy fully independent digital Bots
but you may not need to rip and replace
your existing infrastructures
also there's a common misconception that
RPA could steal our jobs
well that's not true monitoring and
controlling these Bots are completely
the responsibilities of the developer
as a result RPA does not pull down your
existing systems but it leverages them
lastly popularity and high salary
according to Glassdoor the average
salary of an RPA developer in the US is
77 000 US Dollars and in India the
beginning salary for an RPA developer is
around 4.65 lakhs per annum
top tier companies like Dell IBM
Accenture capgemony cognizant among
others are readily hiring RPA Developers
now with that let's move on to the
growth projections of RPA
now looking at the graph here both RPS
software and services
increased by huge amounts during between
2016 and 2020.
according to McKinsey research knowledge
and work automation could have an
economic impact of five to seven
trillion dollars by the year 2025. it
will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers which on which
constitute about nine percent of the
global Workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
High transaction functions will boost
their capabilities and save money and
time with RPA
now this is all you need to know about
why one should learn RPA
but if you're looking to become a
developer let's look at some of the job
roles and responsibilities
RPA developers are responsible for the
creation design development and
implementation of RPA systems
an RPA developer is expected
to provide Guidance with process design
develop test automation workflows
deploy RPA components be it Bots robots
or development tools support the
implementation of RPA Solutions
create process documentation and also
assure the quality of the automation
so moving to the most exciting part
here is an easy question for you to
answer
which of the following is not an RPA use
case
option a email query processing
B data transfer between systems
C payroll processing
or D image recognition
so make sure to leave your answers in
the comment section or the chat section
all right then
moving on so you must be wondering how
simply learn can help you
now if you're looking to make a career
as an RPA developer then I'd recommend
you go through some of the course
courses offered by us
so you could visit our official website
say simplylearn.com
and say RPA
you get a few options and depending on
your requirement you can take up the
appropriate course
so we have RPA training using uipath
all right so you can click on that and
get a brief overview of it
so
this certification training is designed
to help you master RPA processes and
best practices now this mainly focuses
on uipath certification
it also gives you an insight into the
key features
you can opt for your required training
options
and then you have a course curriculum
and then you have eligibility so this
training is ideal for anyone with a
technical background and anybody who
wants to kick start a career in this
field so professionals can also benefit
from this training and be it developers
project managers Architects or product
managers
next up we have introduction to robotic
process automation
now then again you can look at the key
features what it provides you have
different courses for individuals and
businesses
you can go through the description and
if you think this suits your
requirements and you can opt this
and again it gives you the course
overview
if this is what you want to learn then I
think this course is for you
and lastly we have automation anywhere
certified Advanced RPA training course
now this is for automation anywhere
certification so anybody looking for
that should totally go for this
we again have
the overview here the key sale in
features we have training options
and then the criteria and course content
so you could go
go ahead and look at this and then
choose the appropriate one
in this video we will be looking at the
robotic process automation example let
us consider a discussion between John
and Jim John is very curious and wants
to know how and where RPA is used in
different fields Jamie been a developer
helps John in understanding the RPA
examples even if you are curious to know
the applications of RPA then you are at
the right place so let's get started
thank you
the first example is customer service
let's look at the problem statement
a customer representative must
understand and solve the customer
queries carry out the necessary actions
by switching between the various
softwares and applications and inform
the customer
this must wait while the representative
is busy dealing with data sometimes
asking for information that has already
been requested this tends to decrease
customer satisfaction and extends call
duration
the solution requires identifying
frequently Asked customer questions
assessing customer representative
actions in response to those questions
and developing RPS solutions to
facilitate those questions
when several sets of information need to
be coordinated across systems the
customer service representative can
launch a bot the bot completes all
actions in seconds with the Press of a
button
for frequently asked questions a
dashboard can be created a customer
service representative will fill out the
necessary information to receive the
queries and Bots will use that data in
multiple systems to complete the
transaction let's look at an example
consider a scenario where a company was
providing support to the client and the
company was supposed to handle a large
number of calls approximately 20 000
calls per month which required a
significant amount of time spent in the
support team because of the system's
complexity and executive's average time
was about 10 minutes the system was
inefficient and slow resulting in a poor
customer service
with the RPA solution the organization
gained a virtual team that can complete
the task in less than a minute resulting
in a drastic reduction in an execution
time
the RPA bot performs the following task
loading a comprehensive customer profile
obtaining a detailed building
information
user preferences and other user
information are being updated the
solving common but simple customer
issues
let's look at the second example
Financial Service
Financial Service involves compiling and
combining financial information from
various departments and storing the
records in a system data is manually
extracted from a bank statements to
reconcile documents and Link them to its
forms using detailed spreadsheets
to complete the reports business rely on
Excel Legacy software and manual labor
which is tedious and time consuming
solution robots can generate invoices in
seconds prompting clients to pay more
quickly RPA in financial services tracks
and standardizes and validates payments
process orders and avoid Sellers and is
always on top of things such a
disciplined assistant makes the
customers experience less stressful
adding value to the service provider
RBA in finance eliminates the need for
Endless email correspondence and ensures
a smooth payment approval process
matches invoices to responsible parties
and sets deadline reminders
automated data entry speeds up the
process and relieves human employees of
huge tasks this enables precise and
structured invoice processing
consider a financial service company
that's having difficulty extracting data
from financial documents efficiently and
accurately in order to generate treaties
using RPA company implemented an
application that recognized and
processed data this enabled the client
to quickly and cost effectively automate
the task performed by RPA bots in
financial service are investment
management
reconciliation of bank statements
organizing the finances
record of accounts receivables and paid
the third example is HR service
this operation includes numerous routine
steps such as interview scheduling
record keeping resume screening
candidate shortlisting induction
training and onboarding pairing and
firing plays a significant burden on HR
and other support functions such as it
security and Facilities Management
particularly for medium and large
businesses while it is expensive to
build a solution that encompasses all of
these functions and completes the
necessary task for new or departing
employees some employees can be sloppy
with recording absences vacation or in
general using the existing absence
management system
so the possible solution for this is RPA
can be used to collect and Screen
resumes and online application forms
conduct through background checks and
compare the information to all relevant
job requisitions this allows the best
candidates to be shortlisted RPA can be
used quickly to create offer letters for
new employees that are both personalized
and accurate and also validate records
by cross-checking data such as absentee
reports Against Time logged in the
corporate Network and alerting when
information is missing or inconsistent
as in acquisition team of a company
automated aspects of onboarding process
for new employees
previously the onboarding paperwork was
completed manually by one person
consuming a significant amount of
employees time that could have been
spent on more valuable work
this type of work that no one wants to
do day after day the company understands
that an HR department wants to provide a
digital and straightforward experience
the task required a lot of copy and
paste activities with the implementation
of RPA the bot completed the onboarding
paperwork in less time allowing HRS to
spend more time on corporate social
responsibilities hiring Talent
initiatives and improving a company's
reputation
the tasks performed by RPA boards in HR
service are screening resumes onboarding
of new hires attendance management
induction and training employment
management and Survey report
the fourth example is telecom service
the Telecommunications industry involves
high frequency of manual repetitive
rules-based processes all of which are
critical for providing appropriate
Service delivery thus the foundation of
telecommunications is made up of process
that are highly amenable to automation
for telecommunication companies looking
to improve their customer service High
reliability and accuracy of process
outcomes are required
solution the use of robotic process
Automation in Telecom reduces error
rates to close to zero improves data
quality improves customer service and
increases operational efficiency all
while contributing significantly to cost
reduction
RPA technology can capture the business
process task performed by a telecom
company's employees based on the
employee section A well-structured
workflow can be generated which serves
as the foundation for automated process
by mapping each process step with its
significant cost for manual execution it
is simple to determine which action
should be automated to maximize return
on the investment
consider an example a telecommunications
and Media company decided to automate
its order creation and service removal
process to cut costs associated with the
company Speed Booster discount service
and deal with a massive amount of
transactional data
with the implementation of RPA it
becomes simple to automate the order
build process and service removal
activity
the task performed by RPA bots in
Telecom services are
it checks on the credit and SIM card
swapping the solution of customer
complaints reporting customer phone
numbers responding to questions from
partners
okay
the fifth example is healthcare service
Healthcare Systems contain numerous
burdensome tasks that involve
significant resource allocation such as
claim management this results in high
operational cost and slow process
every industry has inefficiencies but
few phase the healthcare industry's
challenges sick regulations regarding
patient data and lack of resources to
deal with such rules building takes time
after a healthcare service is provided
due to manual and repetitive tasks in
the management process
management process include document and
data input processing and evaluation in
addition to the automating time
consuming task patients can schedule
appointments without the intervention of
hospital employees credit to RPA
technology
along with eliminating the need of
resource allocation for scheduling by
allowing patients to reschedule
appointments more quickly this
application can improve customer
relations RTA allows Healthcare
Providers to track and document each
process step in structured log files to
comply with external audits RPA improves
data confidentiality because Bots handle
this process
let's consider an example daily a
healthcare organization deals with the
process of patient transaction Data
customer detailed recording claims to
the process and data reconciliation for
healthcare schemes are some of the
manual process they must streamline
daily the primary goal was to increase
the efficiency of existing approaches to
achieve greater accuracy with reduced
turnaround time
robotic process automation was
implemented at the most significant
possible impact was obtained RPA
platform handled claims processing and
held data reconciliation program
Healthcare was able to reduce turnaround
time with this solution
the task performed by RPA boards in
healthcare services are appointment
scheduling Regulatory Compliance data
entry and supporting analytics to
improve treatment in this video we will
learn about installation of automation
anywhere Community Edition
prerequisite Enterprise control room
requires a server level machine to be
installed the server can be a physical
machine in your data center or a cloud
platform instance Cloud platforms like
Amazon web services Google Cloud
platform and Microsoft azure
the device should have a processor of 8
core Intel Xeon Processor
it should have storage disk space of at
least 500 GB
and network of 1 gigabit Ethernet it is
recommended that you configure the
Enterprise control room Network
bandwidth to be greater than 1 gigabyte
ethernet because Uplink traffic can
quickly exceed one gigabit Ethernet
depending on the complexity of the
automation run
operating system
automation anywhere is compatible with
the operating system such as Windows 10
Windows Server 2012 Windows Server 2016
and Windows Server 2019 automation
anywhere supports both 32-bit and 64-bit
operating system versions
finally the system should have a ram of
16 GB let's look at the features of the
Community Edition
students and developers can use the
automation 360 Cloud platform for free
with the Community Edition it is
completely web-based you can build a RPA
bot in the cloud from any device thanks
to a completely web-based experience
that requires no download utilize the
cloud to gain access to Cutting Edge
Enterprise class technology
the most recent Enterprise class
technology
Community Edition will allow you to stay
up to date with the latest version of
our Enterprise platform AI drag and drop
with direct iqbot integration you can
automate your document Centric process
drag and drop Simplicity with instance
on ease of use
create Bots at any skill level create
Bots using no code low code or bring
your own code options Begin by using
free Bots use pre-built Bots for
personal productivity business
continuity and other purposes
let's look at the installation of
Community Edition
let's go to the browser go to the
automation anywhere official website
automation anywhere.com
after going to the website scroll down
here you can see Community Edition
click on Community Edition
to download the Community Edition free
fill out default fill all the necessary
details and click on get free Community
Edition
once you fill in all the details and
click on get free Community Edition you
will receive an email
so you will receive an email the email
consists of a control room URL a
username and password
so open this control room URL
so click on the control room link a
username password a login page appears
where you need to enter the username and
password so enter the username and
password which you have received in the
mail and login
unlike other editions in Community
Edition there will be no client option
you can develop the bots on the cloud
let us build our first bot let us go to
the control room
so we'll build our first bot so the
first step under the robotic process
automation click on create a bot so
enter the name say first bot
enter the name and click on Create and
edit
so you can see the first bot is
successfully created
Now search for the message box here
double click on the message box to hide
it in the workflow
so enter the message here enter the
message which you want to be displayed
so let us enter say
hello how are you
so we have entered this message
after entering the message click on save
button
and after saving click on run
it's downloading the dependencies
here you can see the message has been
displayed hello how are you
when when you do it for the first time
when you click on the Run button a
pop-up will appear to connect to my
computer
then a file will get downloaded the file
is to install a bot agent the bot will
get connected to the control room then
there will be an option to enable
extension to the Chrome
after doing all that finally finally the
bot is ready to display the message so
here you can see the message has been
displayed in this session we will learn
about automation anywhere tutorial
what is automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a well-known
robotic process automation tool that
enables business to automate end-to-end
business operations
automation anywhere provides powerful
and user-friendly RPA capabilities such
as Cloud native web-based intelligent
automation solution for automating any
complex task
it is a web-based management system that
employs a control room to execute
automated tasks it improves the
efficiency of business process and
reduces the need for human labor
features of automation anywhere
automation anywhere offers an easy to
use interface for building Bots and
designing business process automation
workflows
it supports multiple operating system
such as Windows Linux and Mac OS
it consists of a recorder that works on
a variety of platforms including
Microsoft Windows Citrix web and sap
it consists of different bot views for
collaboration flow view for business
users list view for developers and dual
view for collaboration
automation anywhere supports platforms
like JavaScript Python and vbscript as
well as advanced wearable capabilities
another key feature is its versatile
architecture that allows for the
addition of new command packages
let's look at the automation anywhere
components
the first component is automation
anywhere robotic interface
aari it is a user-friendly interface
that allows business users to
collaborate with Bots users can initiate
process automation provide feedback to
the bots in order for process to be
resumed and escalate request to
additional users for Downstream
processing
Ari that is Automation and your robotic
interface enables Enterprises to unlock
previously unavailable automation
opportunities between humans and the
Bots
iqbot an intelligent document processing
solution capable of reading and
processing a wide range of complex
documents and emails
iqbot intelligently captures classifies
and extracts semi-structured and
unstructured data using RPA and multiple
AI techniques
a long document-centric business process
to be automated end to end
bought inside
the analytics platform that delivers
real-time interactive and intelligent
insights into business process and
operational intelligence
bought inside takes a large amount of
content level and productivity data
generated by deployed Bots and converts
it into insights via automatically
generated and customizable dashboards
foreign
bot an intelligent Business Solution for
Enterprise business that enables end
users to discover automation
opportunities through process discovery
Discovery board focuses on process
automation by capturing document process
identifying opportunities from
business-centric process and
prioritizing opportunities based on Roi
and create Bots automatically
Discovery board collaborates with
business workers to identify automation
opportunities that can maximize the
return on your RBA investment
foreign
let's look at the architecture of
automation anywhere
automation anywhere platform is built
using a distributed architecture
the Enterprise control room a web-based
platform that manages the development
and execution of digital Workforce
provides centralized management bot
creators and Bot Runners are linked to
the Enterprise control room but creators
are software development platforms for
authorizing and customizing automations
bot Runners our runtime system deployed
on the machine that carry out the
automations bot Runners can be installed
on desktops in data centers or in the
cloud let's explore the architecture in
detail
bot creators a bot is a self-contained
task that requires little to no human
intervention to complete the bot Creator
is a customized development aligned for
automation anywhere that is used to
create Bots task editor event Watcher
bot player Auto login and local
scheduler are all included
the bot creator also includes the
ability to create Bots from a device
utilizing the Enterprise client
application
the device is registered with the
Enterprise control room after the bot
Creator user signs in for the first time
and the user can deploy bots on that
device
runners
a bot Runner has the ability to run Bots
from a device utilizing the Enterprise
client application the device is
registered with the Enterprise control
room after the bot Runner users login
for the first time and the user can
deploy bots on that device
ports are run by the board Runner which
is a software machine but Runners can
run Bots at scale after they have been
developed with bot create
control room the Enterprise control room
serves as a single point of management
for all Bots Enterprise control room is
placed on a server in the data center
and configured to work with the other
data center components a reward proxy is
in charge of listening for request for
remote connections and sending them to
the appropriate Specialized Service
using a collection of specialized web
surveys the Enterprise control room
manages schedules executes and
configures various Bots and Bot Runner
capabilities
let's look at the types of bots in
automation anywhere
bought taskbots are used for automating
repetitive tasks based on the rules
these tasks are simple to create and can
reliably complete multi-step procedures
document Administration claims
management HR departments I.T and other
areas benefit from taskbots they
increase production reduce errors and
save money
meta board metabots are more advanced
version of taskbots metabots or
automation building components that help
with Next Generation integration
scalability these are intended for
scalable complex process on a computer
metabots are used to automate
applications application apis visual
captures and integration flow can all be
used to develop metabots
iqbot IQ Bots are the next generation of
intelligent Bots with the ability to
think like humans these Bots are
designed to learn on their own and Carry
Out tasks in accordance with that
learning users can experience the
potential of automation with IQ boards
we choose Advanced cognitive technology
and advanced artificial Technologies
these Bots have capabilities such as
self-learning decision making and
subject matter expertise among others
data can be extracted from
semi-structured and unstructured data by
these Bots
IQ boards also learn to recognize
patterns so that the bot knows exactly
what to do the next time the pattern
appears
IQ Bots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears with
each human confirmation it learns and
improves its ability to carry out the
ACT benefits of using automation
anywhere
time saving an easy to use interface
that allows users of wearing skill
levels to easily use the product and
accelerate the learning process with
instant web-based deployment you can get
started with writing Bots right away
foreign
business adaptability automation
anywhere provides regular updates
ensuring that you are always up to date
on any device anywhere it provides
continuity of operations with high
availability and disaster recovery
low cost of ownership there is no need
for additional infrastructure investment
it gives low cost maintenance a unified
platform for front office back office
and employee applications is provided
foreign
so let's see a demo in this demo we will
create a bot which will automatically
login inside the simply Learn login page
so I'll show you
let's go to the browser I'll go to the
simply launch page
so this is the simply lens login page
so in this page the bot will
automatically enter the email address
password and it will click on the login
button and it will take you inside the
simply launch page
so we'll create a bot
so I'll show you how the bot works
so I have created it let's see the
output first and then we'll get started
with the project
so I'll click on the Run button
it will download all the dependencies
and you can see it's entering the email
address
so it's entering the password and it
will click on the login button
so this is the project this is the
output
so you have seen the output so let's get
started
we'll close this go to the go to the
mail which you received from the
automation anywhere and click on the
controls room link and you will open up
here after coming here click on create a
bot
so enter a name
let's say
will enter as login bot
since we are
creating a project to login
if you want you can give the description
and next click on Create and edit
there are three options here flow list
and dual
in the flow it only shows the flowchart
of what activities or actions you are
dragging and dropping it in the list it
shows the in the form of the list all
the actions and in the Dual it shows the
flowchart as well as the actions Port
actions it is performing
so first we need the browser option
so we'll search for the browser action
so this is the browser action
so the browser package contains actions
that enable you to download file find
broken lines and launch a website so
this package basically supports Internet
Explorer Microsoft Edge and Google
Chrome browsers
so the browser package includes the
actions like close download file get
source code find broken lines go back
open run JavaScript
now for us to open the browser to open
the simply launch website we need the
open option so let's click on the open
double click on the open
so what open does is opens the browser
to a specific web page whichever web
page link We provides it opens that
browser so what we want to open do we
want to open it in the existing tab or a
new tab or a new window so in existing
tab it opens the web page in the
currently open tab
so this existing tab option is only
available in the Google column browser
and new tab opens the web page in a new
tab like select the tab from the list of
the active tabs in the Google Chrome
browser or insert a new window variable
and in the new window this opens the web
page in a new window or of a specific
browser which our browser will choose it
opens a webpage in a new window
so all these options are applicable in
the Google browser
so we will select the new window option
and the browser okay you have these
options Internet Explorer Mozilla
Firefox Chrome and Microsoft Edge so we
will select Google Chrome
and we'll select the link to open
so we should select the link so we'll go
to the simply lands website page
so this is the page we are logging in so
that is why we need the link of this
page so copy the link of this page
and paste the link here
and we need it in the new window
so save it
and let's run and see if this opens in
the new window
let's click on run
okay so till now we are going right so
we have entered the link and we have run
the bot and the bot is opening the
webpage in the new window
so we'll close this
so after this we need the recorder
package so search for the recorder
package
so this is the recorder package in this
we have the capture action so the
capture action from the recorder package
is used to capture an interaction with
the user interface object such as a text
box button Table menu radio button combo
box check box list view link tree and
package tab the capture action enables
you to add single interaction when
building your Bot so let's double click
on capture option
so let's select dual so that we can see
what action it triggers
so after selecting the capture option
so select the browser option browser
window then
click on this refresh windows
so it will show a list of uh so it will
show the list of pages that are open in
the browser
so scroll down
and we need learning on simply
so this is the web page in which we are
logging in so select the web page
go down and let's click on capture
object click on capture object
so first we need to fill in the email
address so you can see here it's showing
a red color box
so click on email address
so it will capture this object of email
address here you can see recording
capture finalization
so the object is captured
scroll down and here you can see action
to take on object what action should be
taken on the object which we have
selected
so we need to enter the text that is the
email address so select set text
and scroll down
and enter what text you want to enter
there
so I'll enter my email ID
now scroll down
you can enter the time how much hour you
want
it is recommended to enter a nine
seconds or 10 seconds but it's optional
so we'll skip it for now
you can see here it's the of the type
user login page
so we have captured the first object
that is email address so we'll save it
and will run and see if it's entering
the email address
here you can see
it's open the webpage in the new window
and it has entered the email address
so let's go back to the control room
close this
your Bot has run successfully
so now that we have entered the email
address we need to enter the password so
we will use another capture
action
and this will set will select the same
browser window
and we'll select the same
learning on simply learn
website
and we'll click on capture object
but now this time we'll capture the
object password
select the password
object
and recording capture finalization
so now that the object is captured we
need to
select the action what action should be
performed
so we will select set text
now that we have selected text
since we are entering the password The
password should be credential
and when the password is credential you
can't enter the password here you need
to pick the password
you need to pick the password from the
locker room
so now that now that I have already
created a credential and entered in the
locker room for me it's showing here
I'll show you how to create a credential
and create a locker room
so we will save it till here for now we
save here
uh let's go to the credential section
here if you go in the manage options you
can see credentials so go in the
credentials
this is the credentials which I have
already created
go to the create credential options
click on it so enter the credential name
say and enter it as username
enter the description if you want any
and scroll down
and enter the attribute name what
attribute are you entering for first we
will enter the email address
so
select email address
and
select the input type as standard
description is optional and enter the
value what is the email address so I'll
enter my email address
scroll down and click on the plus here
to add
so there are two attributes in the login
page right that is the email address and
password so one attribute we have
entered the email address and the other
attribute is the password attribute so
select password and input type as
standard and since we are entering the
password it should be masked
so that no one could see your password
The password should be encrypted so
enter your password Here
after entering the password
so you have created the you have filled
all the credential details click on
create credential
so after clicking on create credential
your credentials will be created
so that is how you create a credential
after creating the credential
so since I have already created the
credential I'll click on cancel
before creating
if you want to create the credential
enter all these details and click on the
create page so I'll click on cancel so
this is once you create the credential
you can see uh like this a credential
whatever you have created it will be
shown here
so this is how you create a credential
now after creating the credential you
need to go to the locker section
and here you can see
create a locker
click on create a locker
so enter the locker room whatever you
want
so let us enter username
after entering the locker room
go to the credential and select the
credential whatever you have created
since I have already entered the
credential in the locker that is why it
is that is why this is disabled for you
so when you are entering the credential
in the locker room for the first time
you can come inside the locker and
select this option check this option and
click on this so this will get
this will get deposited in the locker
this owners and managers section is
disabled the Community Edition so we
can't do any changes in that this will
also be disabled
this will also be disabled go to the
consumers
so enable this
enable this click on the Community
Edition user and
get deposit this in the locker click on
this then scroll down so this is the
last
then when you go back scroll up when you
finish doing all this this create Locker
option will get enabled so when this
option get enabled click on create
locker and your locker will be created
that's how you create a blocker since I
have already created a locker I did not
so this options are not enabled for me
so this option is also not enabled when
you do all these steps this option gets
enabled that is how you create a locker
I hope you have understood how to create
a credential and how to create a locker
so let's go back to the bot which we had
created let's go to the automation
so the bot which we had created was a
login bot
so we had selected the recorder option
in this recorder we had selected the
action
password so we need to enter the
password so
select here go to here
click on pick
and select the locker which we had
created the email address
select the credential that is the email
address credential select the attribute
attribute is the password attribute we
had entered two attributes right one is
the email address and the password so we
are entering the password Here select
the password attribute and click on
confirm
scroll down
here you can see we have picked the
password if you want to enter the time
which is optional
you can see it is of the type user
password
so that's all save it
now we need a one more recorder action
that is to click on the
login button so we'll select for the
search for the recorder
select the capture option
and will select the browser
select the web page
and click on the capture object
so the object which we are capturing now
is the login button so click on the
login button
here you can see recording capture
finalization
so the login button is being captured so
what action should be taken
so we need to click on the login button
here you can see if you have noticed
there is no option to set text why
because this is the login button when we
can't enter the text here so that option
is not here
so from this options we should select
the click option to login so we'll
select the click option
and you can see here it is of the type
login button login
so we have selected the login button
now we'll save it
so we have completed the project in the
first step we have selected the browser
package in browser package we have
selected the open Action which opens the
web page the link page we have provided
into openc webpage in the second we have
selected from the recorder package we
have selected the capture option in
which we have captured the email address
then we have captured the password and
then we have captured to click on the
login button
so let's save it we have saved it so
let's click on run and see
here you can see the web page has opened
in the new window email address has been
entered
password has been entered
and it is clicking on the login page
and it is redirecting to the website
and here you can see the login but login
page has been open
so your Bot has run successfully in this
video we will learn about automation
anywhere Excel operations Excel packages
the Excel package consists of actions
that allow us to automate many of the
tedious tasks while working with
Microsoft Excel spreadsheets
the Excel packages dot automation
anywhere offers are Excel Advanced
package to use the Excel Advanced
package command we must first install
the Excel Advanced package it's utilized
to automate actions involving the
workbook worksheet rows columns and
cells the system must have Microsoft
Office installed the versions of
Microsoft Office that are supported
range from Microsoft Office 2016 to
2019. file formats like dot XLS dot xlsx
are supported by this command and it
also supports the older Excel formats as
well as the advanced Excel actions and
it requires the installation of the
Microsoft Excel application
next we have Excel basic package this
package enables quick spreadsheet
activities for DOT xlsx files without
requiring the MS Excel software to be
installed
Office 365 XL this package provides
commands for working with Excel online
The Office 365 Excel bundle includes
actions that allow you to automate
operations in Microsoft Excel online
if you are using Microsoft Excel 365 via
a web browser you can use the Office 365
Excel package to automate Excel process
let's look at the Excel commands
some of the Excel commands are
open spreadsheet this allows to open the
Excel spreadsheet
close spreadsheet closes a spreadsheet
that was opened using the open
spreadsheet operation the Excel command
identifies the spreadsheet using the
same session name as one used in the
open spreadsheet operation
safe spreadsheet
this command saves a spreadsheet in an
open workbook
activate spreadsheet activates a
specific spreadsheet in an open workbook
it specifies whether to activate the
sheet by index or sheet by name
get cell
this command allows to retrieve the
values of a specific cell as well as the
range of the cell
set cell this command sets the value of
the active cell or a specific cell in an
Excel spreadsheet you can assign a
variable to the cell value
go to cell moves to a specific cell
within a spreadsheet it can move one
cell to the left or to the right of the
active cell and it can move one cell
above or below the active cell or move
to the beginning or end of the column
delete cell
this command deletes the value in an
active cell or in a specific cell within
a Excel spreadsheet
then Excel macro runs a macro that is
stored within an Excel spreadsheet enter
the macro name and specify the
parameters of the macro arguments let's
look at the demo in this demo we will
have two Excel files and we will use
Excel operations and merge these two
Excel files so let's jump into
automation anywhere so what we are doing
is we have two Excel files I'll show you
the files
so this is Excel file one which has
which has a data table of employees and
salaries
and we have another file
Excel file to
which has the data table of employee
names and salads so the file one has
different names employee names and
different salaries and the file to have
different names and different salaries
so we will combine both of these data
tables we'll create a bot which will
combine both of this data table
so let's go to the control room
go to the automation section and click
on create new bot
name the bot
we'll name it as Excel bot
click on Create and edit
so after creating a bot
go to search actions and search for a
step
action and double click on this so what
step action does is it runs a sequence
of commands for example to open a file 1
and file two there are there is a
sequence of steps and at the end of this
project there will be many list of steps
so which will be confusing so just to
avoid confusion we will drag and drop
the step and inside each step there will
be a number of actions
so we have
now that we have selected this action
step
give the title I will name it as file
one
so
go to excel package search for excel
so in Excel advanced
since I have MS Excel installed in my PC
so I will use Excel advanced
scroll down and select open open Action
opens an Excel spreadsheet this action
works with xlsx and XLS and all these
files which you can see here
so now after dragging and dropping open
option
you can select the file path from
control room desktop file or a variable
I have the file on my desktop so I'll
select desktop and I'll browse
so I'll select the file that is file one
and I'll open
so I have selected the file and our file
contains the headers so check this box
and check this specific sheet name so
that you can name the sheet
so our data table is in the sheet1
so type the name of the sheet and open
in read write mode or read only mode so
we'll open in read write mode
and if you scroll down there is session
name so we'll keep it as default
so this much is done next activity
so this action should be inside the step
action so drag and drop it inside okay
next we need get multiple cells
double click on get multiple cells get
multiple cells retrieves the values of
multiple cells in an Excel worksheet
so you can select range of cells to be
returned
all rows or specific rows or cell range
we we will select all rows since we want
to merge all the rows so select all rows
and select the read visible text in cell
or read cell value you can select any
one of this and this session name keep
it as default
and you need to assign value to the
variable so we'll create a variable
since we are using the data table we
will name it as table 1.
okay let's create and select
so we have selected the variable and now
we need to close the file so we'll
select the close action
so the close action closes an Excel
spreadsheet
so double click
and select the close option
here you can you should uncheck the save
changes when closing the file and name
the session as default
okay so step one that is file one so
these three steps so this is done for
file one now we need to repeat this for
file two as well
so we'll save here till now what we have
done okay now we'll repeat this for file
two let's drag and drop step
action
so in step two
name it as file to
we are performing this step for file two
okay now we'll go to excel package
and select open you need to open the
file so basically we are repeating this
about steps and we will select the file
too we'll go to desktop file browse and
select file 2.
so we have selected the file to and this
file also contains headers check this
box and specify the shape name as sheet1
we have the data table in sheet1 so
sheet1 and read and write mode and
session name since the session name for
the file 1 is default and we need to
change here so we'll give it as default
to as the session name okay so this much
is done now next we need get multiple
cells
yes
so double click on get multiple cells
we'll select all rows
and change the session name to default
to
and create a variable here so right
click and create a variable name it as
table2
and create and select
okay this is done
next we need to close the file
so
scroll up
and select the close action
and change the session name for file two
we have keptic session name as default
to so we'll use the same session
okay so this much is done we will save
okay now file 1 and file 2 is created
so this actions are outside the file to
outside the step 52 so we'll bring it
inside
are supposed to be inside
okay
now step one and step two is done next
we need to merge this file so go to the
data table package
so in this data table package you can
see all these actions we need the merge
action this merges two data table
together in a single data table
so
double click on merge data table
okay
so after Double clicking on merge data
table enter the first table name so the
enter the data table name
we will select it as table 1 what we had
created in step one five one and
similarly we will enter the second data
table name so these are basically the
two data tables which which we want to
merge right then enter the name of the
data table in which we want to merge so
we want to merge it in a either we can
merge it in the file 1 or file 2 but we
will create a new file and merge it in
the new file so we'll create a new
variable here
and we'll name it as table 3.
okay so create and select
so new data table is created to create a
new file to write it in a new file there
is an action here right to file this
writes a data table into a specified
file
so select this
and choose a variable that is table 3
variable and enter the file so to enter
the file name select the file path where
you want to create this file so I'll
select the file path of my desktop
and from the desktop
I want to create a file as name result
file
result.csv so I have created this file
so to create this file you need to check
this box create folders and files if it
doesn't exist so this file doesn't exist
I have just named it here now well I
check this box so this file will get
created and check this overwrite
existing file
so that when you run it for a second
time or third time the data doesn't
overlap so every time you run it a new
data has been overwritten so check this
box
and you can change this if you want row
delimiter to new line or column
delimiter comma and all this okay so
this is done
let's save
and let's run
it is downloading the dependencies it
will take a few seconds
or sometimes a few minutes
it's fit so your Bot has run
successfully you will go to the desktop
and check the file which we create here
you can see the result file is created
so we'll open this result file
so here you can see the result file
where both the tables have been merged
so from the row to Tim
till 0 7 this was in the file one and
this last five rows were in the file too
so you can see here both the data tables
have been merged
now you can see here there that there
are rows repeated this row John is
repeated twice
so we don't want the rows to be repeated
we want to eliminate the rows which are
repeated so for that
let's go here so let's close this
and to remove the duplicate rows we have
an option here called remove duplicate
rows remove duplicate rows remove the
duplicate rows from a data types
double click on remove duplicate rows
and take it above right file
okay so in remove duplicate rows select
the data table name we want to remove
duplicators from table 3 which is the
merge date article so select the table 3
variable and now let's save it
and let's run
okay your Bot has run successfully
now we'll go and check if the duplicate
rows have been removed
let's close this and go to the desktop
open the result file
and here you can see there are no
duplicate rows so there was an another
duplicate row here named John and that
row has been removed
and there are no duplicate rows left
that is how you remove the duplicate
rows now let's see now we want this
salaries to be sorted we want this in
order the employee with the highest
salary we need him at the top and the
employee with the lowest salary we need
him at the bottom
so let's go to the control room
to sort the data there is an action
called sort
this sort action sorts a data table on
the basis of column by ascending or
descending order
so double click on this
double click on sort and drag and drop
the sort action
bring it above right file
so install data table enter the data
table name will enter the table 3 which
is the merge data table and we can sort
by column name or column index we'll
sort it by name
and what is the column name which we are
sorting it is the salary scholar right
so
let's type the column name salaries
make sure the spelling is right there
was a to show an error
next we need to select the order in
which we want to sort we will select the
descending order because we want the
employee with the higher salary at the
top so select the descending order
and let's save
let's click on run
foreign there was an error maybe the
error is because I have kept the Excel
sheet open so I'll close the Excel sheet
and run again
so here we go your Bot has run
successfully let's go and check if the
data is sorted let's click on the
results
and here you can see the data has been
sorted in the descending order we employ
with the higher salary is at the top and
it's decreasing in the order and they
employ with the lower salary is at the
bottom
so we have performed this operation of
sorting data let's go back to the
control row let's close this there are
similar other actions in the data table
there is a sign or there is a sign
action so assign action assigns the
value of the source table variable to
the destination Temple variable here the
change column type where you can change
the type of the column if it's an
integer you can change it to string and
if it's interesting you want to change
it to integer then you can use this
action there is clear content there is
clear content action clears all the
content of specified data table and get
the number of rows you can get the
number of rows in this get the number of
rows action and you can delete any
column if you want to then delete row
insert column inside row I have shown a
few actions here you can check out all
of these actions and if you have any
doubt regarding any of these actions you
can comment in the comment section and
I'll try to answer so you can delete
column delete row insert column or
insert row similarly you can join join
two data tables together as per the
column specified as per inner joint
outer joint full joint however you want
you can join the Delta tables and the
merge action we have must do two data
tables here
and you can remove the duplicate rows
and get the number of rows search for
value by search for any particular value
if you want and certain and you can set
the value of a single cell and you can
sort the data in ascending or descending
adder and write to the file so you can
write the data to file
e so these are the actions present in
the data table if you are planning to
attain an interview for an RPA or
automation enabled developer role here
is a comprehensive list of most
frequently Asked automation anywhere
interview questions with answers
we'll first look at the beginner level
questions
what is automation anywhere
automation anywhere is well known
robotic process automation tool that
enables business to automate end-to-end
business operations
it provides powerful and user-friendly
RPA capabilities such as Cloud native
web-based intelligent automation
solution for automating any complex task
it is a web based management system the
templates a control room to execute
automated tasks it improves the
efficiency of business process and
reduces the need for human labor
what are the features of automation
anywhere automation anywhere offers an
easy to use interface for building Bots
and designing business process
automation workflows
it supports multiple operating systems
such as Windows Linux and Mac OS
it consists of a recorder that works on
a variety of platforms including
Microsoft Windows Citrix web and sap
it consists of different bot views for
collaboration slow view for business
users list view for developers and dual
view for collaboration
automation anywhere supports platforms
like JavaScript Python and VP script as
well as advanced variable capabilities
another key feature is its versatile
architecture that allows for the
addition of new command packages
what are the different components in
automation anywhere
automation anywhere robotic interface
aari
is a user-friendly interface that allows
business users to collaborate with Bots
Ari enables Enterprises to unlock
previously unavailable automation
opportunities between humans and Bots
that RPA could not address
iqbot an intelligent document processing
solution capable of reading and
processing a wide range of complex
documents and emails iqbot intelligently
captures classifies and extracts
semi-structured and unstructured data
using RPA and multiple AI techniques
along document-centric business process
to be automated end to end
but Insight the analytics platform that
delivers real-time interactive and
intelligent insights into the business
process and operational intelligence
Discovery bot an intelligent Business
Solution for Enterprise business that
enables end users to discover automation
opportunities through process discovery
Discovery board collaborates with
business workers to identify automation
opportunities that can maximize the
return on your RPA investment
what is an Enterprise control room and
how does it work
the Enterprise control room serves as a
single point of management for all Bots
the Enterprise control room manages
schedules executes and configures
various Bots and Bot Runner capabilities
using a collection of specialized web
services
the Enterprise control room is placed on
a server in the data center and
configured to work with the other data
center components
explain the different type of bots in
automation anywhere
taskbot taskbots are used for automating
repetitive tasks based on the rules
these tasks are simple to create and can
reliably complete multi-step procedures
document Administration claims
management HR departments ID and other
areas benefit from taskbots
metabol metabolts are more advanced
version of taskbots metabots are
automation building components that help
with Next Generation integration
scalability
these are intended for a scalable
complex process on a computer metabots
are used to automate applications
iqbot iqbots are the next generation of
intelligent Bots with the ability to
think like humans these Bots are
designed to learn on their own and Carry
Out tasks in accordance with that
learning
iqbots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears with
each human confirmation it learns and
improves its ability to carry out the
ACT
explain briefly the architecture of
automation anywhere
automation anywhere platform is built
using a distributed architecture the
Enterprise control room is a web-based
platform that manages development and
execution of digital Workforce and
provides a centralized management
bot creators and Bot Runners are linked
to the Enterprise control room but
creators are software development
platforms for authorizing and
customizing automations
bot Runners are runtime system deployed
on machines that carry out the
automations bot Runners can be installed
on desktops in data centers or in the
cloud
what is a bot creator
a bot is a self-contained task that
requires little to no human intervention
to complete the bot Creator is a
customized development client for
automation anywhere that is used to
create Bots task editor event Watcher
bot player or to login and local
scheduler are all included the bot
creator also includes the ability to
create Bots from a device utilizing the
Enterprise client application
the device is registered with the
Enterprise control room after the bot
Creator user signs in for the first time
and the user can deploy bots on the
device
what is a bot Runner
a bot Runner has ability to run Bots
from a device utilizing the Enterprise
client application the device is
registered with the Enterprise control
room after the bot Runner user locks in
for the first time and the user can
deploy bots on that device
Bots are run by bot Runner which is a
software machine but Runners can run
boards at a scale after they have been
developed by the bot creator
explain triggers in automation anywhere
triggers integrate predefined events
into your process reducing the amount of
tasks that users must do repeatedly in
automation anywhere you can use attended
automation to create unique triggers for
numerous apps these triggers can then be
used to launch a bot
add triggers to have the bot execute
automatically whenever a specified event
occurs for instance pressing a specific
key or series of keystrokes
explain the benefits of automation
anywhere
time saving an easy to use interface
that allows users of varying skill
levels to easily use the product and
accelerate the learning process with
instant web-based deployment you can get
started with writing Bots right away
business adaptability
automation anywhere provides regular
updates ensuring that you are always up
to date on any device anywhere it
provides continuity of operations with
high availability and disaster recovery
low cost of ownership there is no need
for additional infrastructure investment
a unified platform for front office back
office and employee applications
it gives lower maintenance cost
what are bought insights
the analytics platform that delivers
real-time interactive and intelligent
insights into business process and
operational intelligence
botinsight takes a large amount of
content level and productivity data
generated by deployed Bots and converts
it into insights via automatically
generated and customizable dashboards
what are the different Excel packages
that automation anywhere offers
automation anywhere offers three
different Excel packages Excel Advanced
package it's utilized to automate
actions involving the workbook worksheet
rows columns and cells the system must
have Microsoft Office installed the
versions of Microsoft Office that are
supported range from 2016 to Microsoft
Office 2019.
Excel basic package enables quick
spreadsheet activities for DOT xlsx
files without requiring the MS Excel
software to be installed Office 365
Excel it provides commands for working
with Excel online The Office 365 Excel
bundle includes actions that allow you
to automate operations in Microsoft
Excel online if you are using Microsoft
Excel 365 via a web browser you can use
the Office 365 Excel package to automate
Excel process
let us look at the intermediate level
questions
explain functions of the following Excel
commands
open spreadsheet allows to open the
Excel spreadsheet close spreadsheet
closes a spreadsheet that was opened
save spreadsheet saves a spreadsheet in
an open workbook
activate spreadsheet activates a
specific spreadsheet in an open workbook
it specifies whether to activate the
sheet by index or sheet by name
get cell allows to retrieve the values
of a specific cell as well as the range
of the cell
set cell sets the value of the active
cell or a specific cell in an Excel
spreadsheet you can assign a variable to
the cell value
go to cell move to a specific cell
within a spreadsheet
delete cell
delete the value of a specific cell
within our Excel spreadsheet
run Excel macro runs a macro that is
stored within an Excel spreadsheet enter
the macro name and specify the
parameters of the macro arguments
explain the types of triggers to start a
bot
email
in email trigger a bot is launched when
a new email message arrives in the given
email service such as Microsoft Outlook
email server or AWS server
file and folder when a predefined file
or folder event occurs it starts a bot
as the trigger you can choose from the
following options like when you make a
new file or a folder or when a file or a
folder that already exists gets
destroyed or when you rename a file or a
folder
the next type is hotkey
when a predetermined combination of
keystrokes is performed on the keyboard
a bot is launched as the trigger you can
use any combination like Control Alt
windows
and Escape are all control keys
particular alphabetical characters are
used in the key
interface when a predetermined event
occurs on the selected user interface
element a bot is launched
some instances of pre-configured events
are a button is pressed by the user or
an application is opened or closed by
the user a checkbox is selected or
cleared by the user
how to record the task with universal
recorder
Step 1 create a new bot or open an
existing bot
then click on the start recording and
select Universal recording step 3
perform the required steps and click on
finish
step 4 edit the actions and click on
Save
let's jump into the automation anywhere
control room and see how to record the
task with universal recorder
so here we are in the control room we
have created a new bot
so let's search for a message box
double click on the message box
enter a message
close message box after 5 Seconds
now go to start recording or you can
press Ctrl r
click on start recording
and select the window which you want to
record
so I'll select the calculator
and click on universal recorder
and now you can perform actions
so I am adding the numbers
so I have randomly performed some
actions now I'll click on finish and
let's finish the
recording
now let us save and click on run
so here you can see the message is
displayed hello it will close in five
seconds and it has closed and the
recording has been played and it shows
the actions which we have recorded
here you can see your Bot has run
successfully
how to clone a bot in automation
anywhere
create a read-only duplicate of the bot
in the private workspace from the public
workspace so you can have a local copy
without checking it out
Step 1 login to the control room as a
bot Creator user and then in public
space click Bots the my bot page is
displayed with the list of folders or
files containing the bot then select the
bot you want to clone click the actions
menu and click clone taskbot the Clone
bot appears in the same folder structure
in the private workspace
so let's jump into the Automation in
your control room and see how to clone a
bot
so this is the my bot folder
so these are the Bots which I have
created
so let's go to this python bar select
this bot and go to the options and click
here copy taskbot
and here you can see a copy of that bot
is been created and name the bot
whatever you want so I'll keep the
default name python bot copy one and
click on copy you can select the folder
where you want to store it
I accept the default folders
and here you can see python bot copy1
has been successfully created
so that is how you clone a bot
explain the following commands delay
command wait command and task command
the delay command is used to delay the
execution of next command for a set
length of time you have the option of
specifying the time in milliseconds or
seconds
weight command the weight command is
used to add a condition that forces the
next set of actions to wait for the
contents of a screen to change before
proceeding
task command task command is used to
start a task within a task or pause it
and stop it
explain predefined variables in
automation anywhere
predefined variables are variables that
provide specific information about the
machine on which the bot is run
the values of a preset variable cannot
be changed by users
below are the examples of predefined
variables clipboard date and time string
and system settings and parameters
explain the date time predefined
variables in automation anywhere
using the date time packages activities
you can manipulate date and time
variables
date returns a date that includes the
hours minutes and seconds day the day is
returned in date format R is a function
that Returns the RS in RS format machine
the device name is written as a string
by the machine
millisecond millisecond returns a value
between 0 and triple 9 milliseconds
minute the minutes are returned in
minute format month month is a function
that Returns the month in month format
seconds the seconds are returned in
seconds format here Returns the current
year in the year format
how are Loops used to control a bot in
automation anywhere
Loops are one of the most powerful board
building constructions Loops are the
instructions that repeat a set of
actions a certain number of times or
until a condition is met
when the loop checks for the completion
of a defined number of iterations or
satisfaction of a condition if not
satisfied the loop is executed the same
conditions are checked repeatedly until
the condition has been satisfied if the
condition is satisfied then the loop is
not been executed
explain error handling and automation
anywhere
error handling in automation anywhere
consists of the error Handler package
that comprises actions that make it
simple to handle exceptions that are
bought encounters and pass control to
the Bots other activities
you can use the error Handler actions to
separate the actions that you can't use
to complete a task from the actions or
to handle an exception
when a bot meets an error handling
exceptions ensure that the work is
complete
how is automation anywhere different
from your iPad
on the basis of single integrated
automation platform automation anywhere
provides intelligent automation platform
like attended automation unattended
automation intelligent document
processing and many more whereas uipath
requires third party products and
integration to deliver a similar
solution
increasing installation and support
complexity modern architecture
automation anywhere provides efficient
Java based microservice architecture
ensuring scalability reducing the cost
of infrastructure and maintenance uipath
on the other hand built on a legacy
window workflow foundation with the last
update released in 2012. the scalability
is slow and difficult due to lack of
modularity
ease of use
in automation anywhere the easy to use
platform enables the regular employees
to create their own automation
but uipath is targeted towards the
developer community and needs more
intervention from it and development
team
most secure and compliant
automation anywhere provides the best
in-class security standard whereas
uipath has incomplete security
certifications that create business and
compliance risk
easier to scale
automation anywhere quickly scales to
thousands of bots in front and back
office no matter the type attended
unattended or document processing
uipath's architecture unable to scale
horizontally and required to duplication
of entire application for every service
expansion
quicker Roi
in automation anywhere the modern
microservices architecture enables a
platform to scale both vertically and
horizontally delivering faster Roi
in uipath with most deployments limited
to a single digit large-scale
deployments become difficult
explain JavaScript package in automation
anywhere the JavaScript package contains
actions that allow a bot to run
JavaScript on Windows Linux and Unix
based devices these activities can
launch JavaScript
the JavaScript includes the following
actions open
this section opens a JavaScript file in
automation anywhere close this action
closes the session and specifies the
same session name from the open Action
run JavaScript action runs a function
within the JavaScript
now let us look at some of the advanced
level automation anywhere interview
questions
how to write inline scripts using python
command in automation anywhere
Step 1 create a new bot
and step 2 drag and drop the following
actions
that is python script open execute
function and python script close
finally add a message box to display the
result variable
let us go to the Automation in our
control group
so I have already created a bot
I'll open that bot
search for the python script
package
from the python skill package drag and
drop the open function
in the open functions specify the
session name if you already have an
existing file on your device then select
the import existing device and enter the
file path
or you can enter the input manually so I
have entered the input manually in which
I have defined a function
function which I have named it as name
and I have called an argument called
string and I have written that argument
so select the python runtime version in
my device python version 3 is installed
so I have selected the three
and then drag and drop the python script
in this enter the session name and enter
the name of function to be executed as
you can see here in the previous open
Action I have entered the function name
as
name
so and enter this in the python script
action enter the name of the function
then argument to the function create a
variable so I have created a variable
and named it as python variable
so and I have assigned the value to this
variable
foreign
called thanks to this variable
and then in the display message
enter the variable which you had created
so we had created
the variable python variable and
assigned it
so enter the variable
just a second
so select the variable and then close
the message box after 10 seconds then
once you open the python script then we
have to close the python script as well
and the session name should be the same
so for in detail explanation and better
understanding check out our tutorial on
automation anywhere using python check
out this video in which I have explained
all the steps in detail e how python is
used in automation anywhere
so now we'll click on Save and
click on Save
and run this
it's downloading dependencies
download independencies
and here you go the message from the bot
is being displayed as thanks this was
the value which we had assigned to the
variable
and the window will close in 10 seconds
how to create a credential in automation
anywhere
Step 1 navigate to Bots and go to the
credentials section
then enter the credential name and the
description for the configured
credential
then enter the attribute name and Supply
the description for the attribute then
select the external keyword and select
input standard or user provided set the
security and click create credential
let's go to the automation anywhere and
create a credential
in the control room
go to manage in the manage you can seek
credentials click on credentials
and if you if you go here you can see
create credential click on create
credential
enter the credential name enter the
credential description which is optional
then scroll down
and enter the attribute name
whatever the attribute you want enter
the attribute name and enter the
description which is optional and
provide the input either you can keep
the input standard or user provided when
you keep the input as user provided when
the credential is added to the locker an
email will be sent to the consumer of
the locker so you will receive an email
but we don't want to receive an email so
we'll keep it as standard
and enter the value
so enter the value of the attribute
which you are creating and you can keep
the value must when you keep it Mars the
value gets encrypted usually we use it
for passwords when you enter the
password we encrypt the value that is
why we select master and you can create
the attribute like this and if you want
you can create multiple attributes click
on plus and you can create the multiple
attributes once you have created the
attributes then when you scroll up here
you can see this option create
credential this option will get enabled
then you click on create credential and
the credential gets created this is how
you create a credential
how to set up a locker and assign
credentials
Step 1 create and assign roles Step 2
create a credential and step 3 create a
locker
so it is very simple let's go to the
control room
go to the credentials sections in this
you can see the lockers option here go
to lockers
and click on create Locker
once you click on create Locker enter
the locker name enter the description
so in the credentials whatever
credentials you have created will be
shown here
so I have already deposited this
credential in the locker that is why it
is disabled for me
so once you have created the Credential
Check this box select the credential and
click here to deposit this credential in
the locker once that is done go to the
owners and select the owner and so your
owner email address will be shown here
select that email address and deposit
that in the locker once that is done go
to managers this is optional and this
manager is not enabled in the community
Edition
and even the participants this is also
not enabled in the community Edition so
skip this two steps and go to Consumers
and in consumers check the Community
Edition user and deposit that in the
locker once this much is done you can
see this option create Locker this
option will get enabled so click on
create locker and the blocker will get
created check out my previous video on
automation anywhere Excel operations in
which I have shown how to create a
credential and how to create a locker in
detail
create a bot to login web page using
automation anywhere actions using the
above question are as follows we will
use the browser package that contains
actions that enable you to download
files find broken lines and launch a
website
it contains a capture action from the
recorder package to capture an
interaction with the user interface
object such as text box button table Etc
let's go to the Automation in your
control room and create a bot to log in
web page using automation anywhere
so this is the login word which I have
already created you can check out our
automation anywhere tutorial in which I
have detailedly explained each step how
to create a bot to login inside any web
page so basically in this we are using a
browser action
in the browser action we will open it in
a new window will browse in the Google
Chrome you can select whichever you want
for now I have selected Google Chrome
and select the link to open
so in this project I will login inside
the simply learns web page so for that I
have selected the link that is the
Link in the simply lunch so go to the
simply lens web page go to the login
page
and I have copied this link of the login
so I've pasted the link to open here
then I have used the recorder package
from the recorder package I have used
the capture action in which in the first
action I'll capture the email address in
the second capture action I'll capture
the password in the third capture action
I'll click on the login button so I have
captured this three action
so let us save and click on run
here you go it has opened the web page
in the new window
Center in the email address password and
clicking on the login button
and it has logged in inside the simply
lunch web page
and your Bot has run successfully
create a bot to merge two data tables
from a different Excel sheets into a new
sheet
so too much to data tables together in a
single data table in automation anywhere
we use merge action from the data table
package
so let's go to automation anywhere so I
have the two Excel files file 1 and file
two so in file 1 I have 6 rows of
employee names and salaries
in File 2 I have five rows of salary of
salaries and employee names so I'll
merge both these tables into a new Excel
sheet so for that let us go to
let us go to the automation anywhere
control room you can check out our
automations anywhere Excel operations
videos in which we have explained all
the Excel operations and actions in
detail in Step 1 I have selected the
file 1 that is I have opened the Excel
file one and assigned a Target multiple
cell actions and close the file
similarly in Step 2 I have opened the
file to and similarly assign the get
multiple cells and close the file two
then from the data table package
foreign
package I have used this merge action
this merges two data tables together in
a single data table so I have used this
so I have used this action so
I'll disable the other actions click on
save and run the file
so the Excel bot is running
and a new file name named as result will
be created on the desktop
so the bot has run successfully let us
go to the desktop and see the result
file which got created let us open this
file
and here you can see both the data
tables have been merged into a new Excel
files six first six rows from the file
one and the next five rows from the file
to have been merged into a single data
table
how to remove duplicate rows from a data
table in automation anywhere
to remove duplicate rows from the data
table use remove duplicate rows action
from the data table package
as you can see in this data table there
is a duplicate row named John
which is repeated twice
so let us go to automation anywhere and
perform action to remove this duplicate
rows so let us close this so if you go
to the data table action here you can
see remove duplicate rows so double
click on this and then you will get the
double click on remove duplicate rows
and into remove duplicate rows select
the data table name so I'm selecting the
data variable which I created so just
specify the data table name and the
automation anywhere will remove the
duplicate rows so let us click on Save
and
let us run
here you can see the Excel bot is
running
it is opening both the Excel files it is
taken for duplicate rows and your Bot
has successfully run so let us close
this and go to desktop
and here you can see the duplicate row
has been deleted so there was one more
duplicate row with the name John so that
row has been deleted so this is how you
delete duplicate rows in automation menu
from the Excel from the data table the
last question how to sort data in the
data table using automation anywhere to
sort data in a data table automation
anywhere provides a short action from
the data table package
so if you look at this data table you
can see the salaries column the salaries
is not sorted so we'll sort this salary
column in the descending order the
employee with the highest salary will be
at the top and the employee with the
lowest salary will be at the bottom so
let's close this
and will enable this sort data action so
what you have to do is Select sort data
action from the data table package once
you select this specify the data table
name and the column name so we want to
sort the column salaries then select the
order in which you want to sort will
sort it in the descending order click on
Save and click on run
here you can see deploying to the
computer downloading the dependencies in
the bot is running
so your Bot has run successfully let's
go to desktop and open the file results
and here you can see the data is sorted
in the descending order they employ with
the highest salary is at the top
similarly in the decreasing order the
employee with the lowest salary is at
default so let's begin by understanding
who is an RPA developer
now generally speaking an RPA developer
is someone who works cross-functionally
with business operations and business
analysts to create an optimize workflow
processes however this is a relatively
new career path and many organizations
formal titles for RPA developers differ
now other similar positions may include
titles like process designer or
automation architect but no matter the
title the role of a successful RPA
developer involves to design develop and
Implement RPA systems
in order to automate the business
process an RPA developer will be
required to create workflow diagrams and
strategically document the
implementation he is also responsible
for bug fixes so coding skills are
important now in order to be a
successful RPA developer you must have
the ability to navigate various
appropriate Technologies such as uipath
or automation anywhere
next up is RTA growth projections
now looking at the curve both RPS
software and services increased by huge
amounts between 2016 and 2020 and Beyond
according to Nexus day research
knowledge and work automation could have
an economic impact of about five to
seven trillion US dollars per year 2025.
it will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers which constitute up to
nine percent of the global Workforce now
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
High transaction functions will boost
their capabilities and save money and
time without you
now that we've established that RPA has
a steep growth curve let's look at the
RPA job roles that you should look out
for
we have the RPA developer senior RPA
developer RPA process architect
RPA developer senior Consultants project
manager lead developer business analyst
and RPA data analyst
now these job roles come with specific
responsibilities depending on the
designation
however there are a few common
responsibilities of an RPA developer
let's go ahead and check them out
now the first one is strategic planning
skills now planning is a crucial phase
in any development life cycle the RPA
developer regardless of the designation
should possess the aptitude to ensure
strategic planning planning includes the
design development and implementation of
RPA systems this also helps streamline
the business
next up is strong analytical skills now
to understand the client's requirements
in cater to the needs accordingly is
crucial
analytical skills are also important to
predict or identify potential bugs and
errors and rectify them
now this skill is especially required if
you're involved in the overall
development
next we have strong problem solving
skills now this again is extremely
crucial to predict any outages and they
put the entire unit to overcome any
unforcing interruptions from the
business perspective as well problem
solving skills play a significant role
in ensuring smooth conduction of tasks
experience in any programming language
such as C C plus plus python Ruby Java
or dot net is also important
hands-on experience on RPA tools and
cognitive platforms such as blue prism
automation anywhere uipath open spam Etc
is necessary communication skills are
pivotal for any organization the
developer should be outspoken and
articulate any new ideas you should also
be confident to raise concerns and be as
transparent as possible in the long run
this only proves to be helpful to the
organization
lastly we have exposure to SQL now
experience with database be it SQL or
nosql is highly prepared it's always an
added Advantage if you have the
knowledge about accessing and managing
databases
next up we have RPA developer Saturdays
now the salaries will differ depending
on the location your experience and also
the designation
now in the US here are the job salaries
and the roles according to Glassdoor an
RPA developer in the US earns around 76
000 US dollars per year
the NRP developer senior consultant
earns around 99 000 US dollars per year
an RPA process architect earns an
average salary of 95 000 US Dollars and
a senior RPA developer earns an average
salary of 92 000 US dollars
an RPA project manager earns around 73
000 US dollars per annum an rple
developer earns an average salary of 99
000 US dollars per annum nrpa business
analyst earns around 68 000 US dollars
per annum and the data analyst earns
around 62 000 US dollars per annum
moving on to India the average salary of
an RPA developer is around 5 lakhs 98
000 rupees that of a senior consultant a
senior RK developer and an RPO lead
developer is around 14 lakhs per annum
is around 5 lakhs 40 000 rupees
now let me quickly run you through a
sample resume of an RTA developer now
this is just a template and you can
alter it according to your needs first
up is your general information like name
phone number and your email ID
then you can give a quick description
about yourself and your strengths you
can also mention the objective as to why
you're applying and what you're looking
for in the organization
you can include your LinkedIn profile
link and your GitHub link one look at
your LinkedIn profile is enough for
anybody to gather all the information
necessary so make sure that is updated
moving on you could mention your
experience now here you would have to
mention the names of your previous
organizations along with your
designation and the tenure you could
also include your key responsibilities
in these organizations
along with the responsibilities you
could also mention the awards that you
received in your organizations
next up is your educational background
you can mention the university that you
graduated from and is required that you
have a degree in computer science you
can also go ahead and mention your GPA
the next section is skills now this is
pretty cliche in the technical skills
section you could mention about
different RPA tools that you've worked
on if you're good at a particular
programming language go ahead and
mention that as well
as mentioned earlier any experience in
database management is an added
advantage
if you have any experience go ahead and
mention that moving on to non-technical
skills you could mention any
extracurricular activities that you're
proud of some soft skills that you feel
worth mentioning can be added in this
section mentioning the languages that
you know can also boast your resume
now given all this it's fundamental that
you do not lie on your resume
first let's understand who an RPA
developer is
now generally speaking an RPA developer
is someone who works cross-functionally
with business operations and business
analysts to create and optimize workflow
processes
now however this is a relatively new
career path and many organizations
formal titles for RPA developers differ
now other similar positions may use
titles like process designer or
automation architect
but no matter the Titan the role of a
successful RPA developer requires
specific skills and best practices like
documentation and planning
now in order to automate a business
process an RPA developer will be
required to create workflow diagrams and
strategically document the process prior
to implementation
now he may also be responsible for
testing and Bug fixes so coding skills
are also important
now in order to become a successful RPA
developer you must have the ability to
navigate through appropriate
Technologies such as uipath or
automation anywhere
however there are a few prerequisites to
become an RPA developer
well it's not very hard but a little
prep is necessary
so let's go through them one by one
first up is strategic planning now
planning is a critical phase in any
development life cycle
the RPA developer regardless of the
designation should possess the aptitude
to ensure strategic planning
strategic planning basically includes
design development and implementation of
RPA systems this also helps streamline
the entire business to optimize the
efficiency
next up is analytical skills now again
as the name suggests it's crucial to
analyze the information and make
decisions to maximize your efficiency
right now these are skills that one
develops when they're exposed to it so
over a period of time you're going to
develop these skills not to worry about
it now
next up is problem solving skills now
these skills are again crucial to
predict any potential outages and equip
the entire unit to overcome any
unforeseen interruptions
from the business perspective as well
problem solving skills plays significant
role in ensuring smooth conduction of
tasks
experience in programming languages like
say C plus plus C python Ruby Java is
also crucial
next up is hands-on experience on RPA
tools and cognitive platforms like
blueprism automation anywhere Redwood
openspan Etc
now other General skills include
communication skills as well now this is
pivotal for any organization now the
developer should be outspoken and should
articulate new ideas
now that you're familiar with the skills
required let's look at the job
description for an RPA developer and
some of his responsibilities
so here's a screenshot of the job
advertisement posted by IBM
as mentioned some of the
responsibilities include crafting
automation process Solutions coding and
scripting in any of the automation tools
configuring new automation using call
automation tools communicating with
business analysts and clients building
and documenting best procedures
supporting the operational teams during
any rollout phases supporting existing
processes and implementing change
requirements I am successfully managing
any sort of issues so if you're aspiring
to become an RPA developer then these
are some of the job responsibilities
that you will have to readily take out
if you're still wondering if this field
has scope for development in the coming
years let me clarify it for you so let's
go ahead and look at the RPA growth
projections and salary
according to Gartner robotic process
automation software grew up by 63 in
2018 making it the fastest growing
segment of the global enterprise
software Market
now the growth curve has also been
steadily increasing since 2016 and
continues Beyond 2020. number is also
predicted that RPA will touch more than
230 million knowledge workers which
constitute up to say nine percent of the
global Workforce
now any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
High transaction functions can totally
benefit from RPA so if you're still
skeptical about picking up RPA I hope
this clarified it for you
so moving on to Saturdays in the U.S the
average salary is available is around 76
000 US dollars
in India is around 6 lakh rupees per
annum
so the company is
Volvo and Accenture among others
moving on here are a few tips to
Kickstart your RPA career
so let's go ahead and look at them one
by one
first up is to choose your RPA platforms
now all RPA tools have graphical user
interface or guis but it's really
helpful to understand the underlying
technology now this comes in extremely
handy when the developer has to create
more complex say personalized or
Advanced Bots
so if you are a python developer then
you can start off by working with Argos
Labs so this allows the developers to
build plugins with almost no effort from
the existing python code
so if you're a python developer then you
can start off by working with Argos Labs
now this really allows developers to
build plugins with literally no effort
and if you're a dotnet developer then
you can start off with uipath or
automation anywhere's Community Editions
so if you're a Java developer then you
can start off with automation anywhere
and if you're a developer with no
experience then you can begin with any
of the leading RPA providers
now tip number two is to start building
there are plenty of free materials and
guides to help you begin your RPA
Journey so some of the famous or
well-known RPA tools are blue prism work
Fusion uipath automation anywhere
Etc so just start working on them
tip number three is build your GitHub
repository
no matter how small or simple you think
your project is go ahead and put it on
your GitHub repository this totally adds
credibility to your profile even if
you're attending interviews one look at
your GitHub repository is going to make
them realize how good of a developer you
are
tip number four is to take up
freelancing projects now again to start
off you can take up say non-paid or even
low paid projects some of the websites
that you could look up are upwork
freelancer freelancer people per hour
so tip number five is to start a blog
now having your own blog will add
credibility to your profile no matter
how less you've worked on any projects
you can go ahead and type in all the
information you want recruiters can also
have a glance at your profile you're
definitely gonna get some extra points
for this
tip number six is to ensure you update
your resume and profile now keep your
resume and profiles updated on all job
portals like LinkedIn indeed Simply
Hired and Monster
so these were some simple tips to help
you become an RPA developer there are
several RPA courses that you can take up
but if you're looking for a well-curated
concise syllabus then you can head to
our official website and type in
RPA so let's do that
you can go ahead and search for RPA
now a list of courses will appear and
depending on your requirement you can go
ahead and choose the appropriate one
you can also go through the overview
to understand what's covered in the
course
so with that we have come to end of this
automation anywhere full course if you
enjoyed watching it make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and press the Bell icon
to never miss an update thank you so
much for being here watch out for more
videos from us until then keep learning
and stay tuned to Simply learn